special counsel Robert Muller is
bombarding the Trump White House with
requests for documents the former FBI
directors gathering information for his
ongoing investigation into Russian
meddling in the election Jeff Pegues is
in Washington with the areas those
documents cover Jeff good morning to you
good morning this request is a clear
indication that the special counsels
office is investigating the president's
actions according to the New York Times
there are 13 different areas that
investigators want more information
about CBS News has confirmed that among
them were this year's resignation of
national security adviser Michael Flynn
the firing of FBI director James Comey
and the president's meeting in the Oval
Office a day later with top Russian
officials where the president reportedly
said commis firing or leave great
pressure on him the White House is
cooperating also CBS News has confirmed
that last year Trump campaign chairman
Paul Manafort sent a message to a
Russian oligarch with ties to Vladimir
Putin pledging to brief him on the
campaign Manafort spokesman says the
email was an oculus but investigators
see that email is another important
piece of this puzzle